あなたは過去48時間、ミニマル版を
実際に使ってきました。Trap Scoreも見て、
“シールドを持つ”感覚も
体験したはずです。ですがあなたが
スコアを見ている間にも、クジラたちは
すでに進化しています。ミニマル版は
入口を見せるだけですが、フル
プロトコルは“部屋全体”を見せます。
今この瞬間も、機関アルゴリズムは
偽のシグナルを重ねて、あなたの
FOMOを誘発しています。罠が閉じる時、
ミニマルなシールドでは足りないかもしれません。
必要なのは“フル・ビジュアル・インテリジェンス・スイート”。4つの
AIエンジン、Grok、GPT、Gemini、
CryptoQuantが完全同期で動きます。リアルタイムの
クジラ追跡、センチメント分析、
3秒判断。これはもはや
“トレード”ではなく、不公平なほどの優位性です。
新たなディフェンダーを歓迎するため、
プロトコルキャンペーンを開始します。次の
50名限定で、すべてを
50%オフで解放できます。これは
“1日1ドル未満”で手に入る
完全な機関レベルの防御です。しかし50枠が
埋まった瞬間、このリンクは失効し、
価格は倍になります。あなたの資金を
運任せにしないでください。今すぐ
ディフェンスプロトコルをアップグレードしましょう。チェックアウトで
コード「defend50」を入力してください。フルアカデミーへ
ようこそ。一緒に勝ちにいきましょう。